christmas in your house
so
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
so
um
[Music]
yes
hmm
don't clash here don't till it
move then ground there
and let it come off let it come off
and enter
in you're not
aiming now you're not
has to be
[Music]
get ready to pause you're bracing that's
why you're
round
even though i'm doing the arm technique
it's not me taking his arm
and going like that
same thing you don't go like this and
then clash with the elbow
you're pushing that elbow that's a clash
that's a young young class
if you didn't push it because he stopped
early and turned around
oh that's a choreography
his job was to file this place
oh it's not gonna stop you're pushing it
if you so when you come around like this
there's a
clash right there
so this one goes this way
right here and he ends up
hitting that round boom
okay
if i bring that over here can you see
you're going to clash on the elbow
[Music]
i have a chat
then i do the distal
and lever okay and not like this
you're going to clash here and you're
setting up
the spinning back fist boom
here
clear the line no
here here's his intention that's what he
hits
then just go ahead and
there are versions where you can make
the elbow
yin then you won't have a young on young
class
this is not one of them so some of those
so the arm is going to go parallel you
see that
but if i go in here that's going to be
you know i'm saying and then bring it in
his elbow is still going that way
well my face is attacking his face
so i let the elbow go around me and i
attack his face
instead that's not possible in this
what he was aversion you can't
i can't get there i cannot get inside
his face
so anytime his arm goes parallel around
this elbow has not been made yen
not by the prescribed attack
a choreographed bouquet will do it
but that's not the art okay
so when my arm his arm is parallel
and the elbow came in like this you see
it's always going to be the hand
that's pushing on his mouse okay
and in this case his elbow is pushing on
me so it's a yang and yang clash
which is if i you're now
logging in so i come in he pulls the car
up and you can see
there's a clash right here but we can't
always go
like see but my
my job was to wound
this place not to come in
and then turn
so the second his hand moves my
hand this way and my arm is parallel you
can use it
as a sign that there's a clash thing
okay if the hand is parallel he's going
to need the elbow
to do it or i'm going to be the one to
reconcile the clutch
which is not right so what we're doing
instead
is having him land with his
his energy on this
if you look at his forearm it's
vertical you see
not parallel to the ground
but his energy is going here around the
corner
and let that hit the ground
boom here
so it's going around and
around and
but in the aikido way
so i'm not projecting he is hitting the
ground
not me pushing him away he comes in
not here around you see that difference
he goes in
okay just to there
oh
let's go uh
i have one skill set here
my next skill set is going to be
developed
on this yin blend
but it's happening in a twerking motion
which is going to cultivate my body
so just for conditional reasons i don't
want to go straight
you see that i
wanna torque torque torque my body
torque my body
but tactically yeah i'm just pushing the
guy
i want him laid out so when i come in
the spiral is going to take the length
of his body
do you see
big tall people first of all they're
going to be stronger than you you're not
going to be able to push them
but let's assume you can't they still
turtle up on you
you need to be able to
prone someone else being able to do that
is going to torque my tissues
and it's going to give me that skill
that this goes through his body through
his body
not into the shoulder out into his elbow
from where i'm touching into his body
same skill set here in his body
okay that's the drill get it right
okay so just like all the other versions
that we have
he's resisting he's not i'm not doing
this and overpowering him
he's resisting so i let it go around me
do you see yes it flares him out
yes it conditions me but there's also
still a yin young consistency he's
resisting
it goes around
he's doing that he's pushing he doesn't
want me to take him down
so i'm going like this do you see
not doing that stuff just taking this
energy
energy boom around me
no don't peddle this it just goes around
you
around you okay try it again
on my elbow you can i have to move my
hands in the same corky pattern
okay so we've been doing the shiva says
eight count and i showed you without the
sword but my hands don't go
turn turn wrist turn elbow
elbow shoulder so same thing
not like this
[Music]
in a way i'm throwing him
that way you see i'm gonna throw him
onto the ground
you get it so i'm going the same way
he's going
you let her down if my hand just goes up
it's not it's a clash now i'm pulling
him
you see i have to get on the other side
of the grip
on the other side of the grip you see
how i'm doing that
so when his energy comes in i'm on the
other side of the grip
got it a tool you can use
is try to hit him with your
elbow boom
[Music]
if you go like this you can't hit with
your elbow
now your elbow is coming in
and also it helps that disconnect
if you keep sparing them in the ribs
because they don't project out
there
[Music]
it makes you turn out there
okay try it